>> Tucker: AFTER HE TESTED
POSITIVE FOR THE CORONAVIRUS
WHICH WAS A SCARY MOMENT, CNN’S
CHRIS CUOMO STARTED BROADCASTING
HIS SHOW FROM HIS BASEMENT.
FROM HIS BASEMENT, HE DELIVERED
FIRM ORDERS TO ALL AMERICANS TO
STAY HOME, NO MATTER WHAT.
>> WHILE MOST AMERICANS ARE
STAYING INSIDE OR SHOULD BE, IF
THEY’RE NOT OUT PROTESTING LIKE
FOOLS, THEY ARE NOT HAPPY ABOUT
BEING TOLD TO STAY HOME.
STAYING HOME SAVES LIVES.
AND THE REST OF US SHOULD BE
STAYING AT HOME FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT WE LOVE, TO KEEP US FARTHER
APART WILL ULTIMATELY BRING US
CLOSER TOGETHER.
NO MATTER WHERE THE VIRUS GOES.
THE WAY TO STOP IT WILL ALWAYS
BE THE SAME.
OUR COLLECTIVE CONSCIENTIOUS
ACTIONS, STAYING HOME.
>> Tucker: HEY, SCAMPER BACK
TO YOUR HOVELS.
GO INSIDE, DO YOU HEAR ME?
AT THAT EXACT MOMENT, WHILE
CHRIS CUOMO WAS DEMANDING THAT
AMERICA GO INSIDE AND GET BACK
TO THEIR OWN HOMES, HE WASN’T
TAKING THE SAME ADVICE.
IT TURNS OUT, AT THAT MOMENT HE
WAS BREAKING QUARANTINE HIMSELF
DESPITE AS WE SAID BEING
POSITIVE FOR THE CORONAVIRUS.
ONE DAY, HE WAS SPOTTED BY A
PASSING BICYCLIST WHO GOT INTO A
TIFF WITH HIM.
CUOMO ATTACKED THE MAN LATER.
LISTEN.
>> I DON’T WANT SOME LOSER, FAT
TIRE BIKER TO BE ABLE TO PULL
OVER AND GET IN MY FACE AND IN
MY SPACE.
I DON’T WANT TO HEAR IT.
>> Tucker: DAVID WHALEN IS THE
LOSER FAT TIRE BIKER IN
QUESTION, THE CYCLIST CHRIS
CUOMO TINGLED WITH.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT WITH HIS
SIDE OF THE STORY.
I DON’T THINK I’VE EVER HAD ONE
ON THE SHOW, WE’RE HAPPY TO
START TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
TELL US ABOUT YOUR EXCHANGE WITH
MR. CUOMO.
>> WELL, FIRST I’D LIKE TO SAY I
PROBABLY COULD BEAT HIM IN A
BIKE RACE EVEN THOUGH HE’S A LOT
OLDER THAN ME, I MEAN YOUNGER
THAN ME.
THE IMPORTANT THING IS IT WAS
EASTER SUNDAY, EVENING, IT WAS
CHILLY AND COLD.
I GREW UP ABOUT A THOUSAND FEET
FROM WHERE HE IS BUILDING HIS
NEW HOUSE, NOTHING BUT A STEEL
FRAME.
I GO BY, DOWN THE TRAIL THAT
RUNS PAST WHERE HIS NEW
STRUCTURE IS BEING BUILT AND
THERE’S A BUNCH OF PEOPLE THERE,
I’VE BEEN WRITING FOR SEVEN OR 8
JUST WALKING.
AND A WOMAN SAYS MAY I HELP YOU,
I SAID NO I’M JUST WALKING.
AND SHE STARTS WALKING A LITTLE
CLOSER, AND THEY’RE PRETTY FAR
AWAY.
I HAVE VERY GOOD EYES, AND CHRIS
CUOMO TURNS AROUND AND I MICHAEL
HE SPOKE, IT’S CHRIS CUOMO.
I’M FAIRLY OUTSPOKEN, I JUST
SAID DON’T YOU HAVE THE
CORONAVIRUS?
SHOULDN’T YOU BE QUARANTINED?
I THINK HIS NEXT WORDS WERE WHAT
THE HECK DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS?
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THE RULES
RULES?
HE CONTINUED TO COME CLOSER AND
CLOSER, AND I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
HE’S LIKE ALL BOILING POT, YOU
COULD SEE HIS HEAD GETTING MORE
AND MORE ANGRY.
AND I SAID SO ARE YOU GONNA LOSE
YOUR TEMPER LIKE YOU DID ON THE
GUY AT SHELTER ISLAND?
BASICALLY, I JUST SAID YOU HAVE
CORONAVIRUS, WHAT ARE YOU DOING
OUT HERE?
YOU’RE SUPPOSED TO BE HOME.
AND I HAD NOT HEARD WHAT YOU
JUST PLAYED ABOUT HIS QUOTES
ABOUT HOW HE WAS TELLING PEOPLE
TO ACT.
I SEE HIS SHOW OCCASIONALLY, AND
THEN AT ONE POINT I SAID I’M
MOVING ON.
I SAID YOU’RE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
OUT HERE, NOBODY HAD GLOVES ON,
NOBODY HAD MASKS ON, THERE WAS
THREE CHILDREN, YOUNG
ADOLESCENTS AND I BELIEVE HIS
WIFE, I’M PRETTY SURE I HAVE
SEEN PICTURES NOW.
AND THEN THERE WAS A THIRD ADULT
ADULT.
SO, YOU KNOW, THEY’RE OUT THERE.
YOU PROBABLY HAVE CABIN FEVER
LIKE
EVERYBODY THAT IN THIS SITUATION
HAS,
AND MAYBE IF THEY HAD SAID WE
HAVE MASKS, WE JUST DROVE OUT
HERE, THEY DON’T LIVE THERE.
IT’S A STEEL STRUCTURE.
I KIND OF UNDERSTAND, I WOULD
HAVE JUST MOVED ON.
BUT HE TOLD ME HE WAS GOING TO
MEET ME, AND HE GOES YOU WILL
MEET ME OVER THIS, YOU WILL MEET
ME AGAIN OVER THIS.
AT THAT POINT HE’S NOW GETTING
ABOUT 40 FEET AWAY.
>> Tucker: HE WAS IN FULL VOID
RATE AT THIS POINT, HE SOUNDS
ALMOST DANGEROUS.
HAVE YOU BEEN TESTED BECAUSE YOU
CAME INTO CONTACT WITH AN
INFECTED PERSON WHO WAS WITHIN A
6 FEET IF YOU?
>> WE DON’T GET TO GET TESTED,
US NORMAL HUMAN BEINGS.
WHICH IS ONE OF THE CRAZIER
THINGS ABOUT THIS WHOLE THING.
IF YOU’RE WEALTHY, IF YOU HAVE A
LOT OF CLOUT AND THIS AND THAT
YOU CAN GO GET TESTED.
BUT FOR MOST NORMAL PEOPLE, YOU
CAN’T GET TESTED.
I MADE MY OWN MASK WEEKS AGO, I
HIT IT WITH ALCOHOL EVERY DAY.
I HAVE ONE PART-TIME EMPLOYEE, I
DON’T LET HIM WITHIN 10 FEET OF
ME.
MY DAUGHTER IS A DOCTOR AT
JOHNS HOPKINS, I GET LECTURED BY
HER FOREVER.
AND I YELL AT PEOPLE WHEN I SEE
THEM BREAKING THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
>> Tucker: I CAN SEE BY, THE
LAST THING YOU NEED IS TO GET
INFECTED BY A CNN ANCHOR WHO
CALLS YOU A LOSER, I DON’T THINK
YOU ARE AFTER THIS
CONVERSATION I THINK YOU
HAVE A REALLY GOOD POINT.
I APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON
TONIGHT, I HOPE YOU’RE NOT SICK.
THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: I BACKED AWAY, THEY
DIDN’T GET WITHIN 6 FEET OF ME.
BUT THEY STARTED GETTING CLOSER
AND I SAID YOU KNOW SOMETHING, I
WASN’T TRYING TO ANTAGONIZE THE
GUY.
IT WAS REAL SIMPLE.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING OUT HERE?
YOU’RE ON TV EVERY NIGHT.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU ARE
WISE, I WOULD BACK AWAY TOO.
DAVID, THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.